[Musique]
l'actualité de ce 2 février c'est
également l'enquète pour menaces visant
le professeur de philosophie didier
lemaire classée sans suite le parquet de
versailles abandonne les investigations
sur les attaques qu'auraient subies
l'enseignant attrape faute d'éléments
probants ce dernier nous a confié ne pas
être surpris les propos retenus pouvant
s'apparenter à des opinions le maire de
trappes qui s'était opposé aux
professeurs à poster de son côté un
billet sur son compte facebook
ce professeur de philosophie était donc
bel et bien un mythomane qui a inventé
des menaces fictives pour exister
médiatiquement
cet homme pathologiquement attirés par
les projecteurs médiatiques aura commis
beaucoup de dégâts et sali la réputation
d'une ville de ses habitants et en
particulier de ses élèves à des propos
qui pourraient laisser place à un
nouveau dépôt de plainte pour
diffamation la zone à faible émission ne
sera élargie à l'intérieur de l'a86 en
ile-de-france qu'au début de l'année
prochaine l'entrée en vigueur de cette
mesure devait intervenir au 1er juillet
2022 mais la métropole du grand paris
attend toujours des engagements de la
part de l'état autorisé des contrôles et
des verbalisations automatique mais
aussi la possibilité pour la métropole
de débloquer des prêts à taux zéro pour
aider les foyers les plus modestes a
changé de véhicule
les interdictions de circulation semaine
de 8h à 20h concerneront les véhicules à
creed r 3 ou plus à savoir notamment les
voitures essence immatriculés avant le
1er janvier 2006 où les diesels datant
d'avant le 1er janvier 2011
plus que jamais la branche des services
de l'automobile les organismes de
formation et les entreprises recrutent
donc il ya des opportunités et on
encourage vraiment les jeunes et les
salariés en reconversion professionnelle
et les demandeurs d'emploi à venir dans
nos formations parce qu'il ya vraiment
des opportunités d'embauché à l'issue le
message a été martelé lors des dernières
journées portes ouvertes du campus des
services de l'automobile et de la
mobilité à guyancourt la filière recrute
à l'an dernier les services de
l'automobile regroupait plus de 500
mille professionnels exerçant plus d'une
centaine de métiers au sein de 150 mille
entreprises cinq organismes vous
attendent ici pour vous former autour
des métiers de la voiture de la moto et
du vélo que vous soyez en formation
initiale formation continue ou en
reconversion du bts au master en passant
par le bac pro les possibilités sont
nombreuses l'inscription se fait
notamment pour les étudiants
parcours sup la plateforme qui a ouvert
ses portes le 20 janvier triel-sur-seine
s'apprêtait à célébrer pour la première
fois le nouvel an chinois le 5 février
des animations des déambulations auront
lieu dans les rues pour le moment les
répétitions se poursuivre ce que vous
voyez derrière moi ce sens les
répétitions du nouvel an chinois puisque
à triel sur seine
ils nous ont rappelés en tant qu'école
de kung fu pour organiser pour faire des
festivités du nouvel an chinois pourquoi
une école de coups parce qu'en fait que
vous voyez derrière moi ce sont toujours
des exploits techniques physiques
c'est extrêmement fatigant et donc les
villes prenait toujours l'école de kung
fu local pour pouvoir animer le dragon
animer les lions animer les armes et à
triel mais samedi prochain vous allez
voir tout ça réuni à la fois dans les
rues de la ville avec bien sûr des
percussions les bêtas parce qu'il faut
faire beaucoup de bruit
donc ça c'est du mauvais esprit des
mauvais esprits depuis quelques temps il
y en a donc on va chasser tous les
mauvais esprits revenir un peu un esprit
festif
rendez vous à partir de 16 heures dans
les rues commerçantes un village des
saveurs sera aussi proposée grâce à un
petit coup de pouce du destin
batman c'est moi ce 2 février sortie en
salles de super héros malgré lui
l'illinois philippe lachaux et sa bande
à nouveau sur grand écran pour une
parodie des films marvel et dc comics
comédie et action pour cet hommage aux
principales franchises américaines que
la troupe est venu présenter dans les
yvelines récemment en fait elle vient du
ce sont 18 on a passé nous parmi nos
meilleures années dans le 78 avec phi
phi et du coup forcément quand on
revient ici qu'on présente le film dans
les yvelines on est hyper content ça
nous touche et puis ça nous fait quelque
chose donc c'est important pour nous
nouria de la celle saint cloud donc nous
le cinéma à l'époque c'était cinéma de
parly 2 on y aller tout le temps une
fois là on y allait en bande et tout
donc ouais retour aux sources on adore
eux aussi sont originaires des yvelines
de montfort l'amaury à grégoire ludig et
david marsais les deux comédiens du
palmashow sont de retour avec leur
nouveau film les vedettes sortie prévue
le 9 février avant première ce 5 février
à 20h30 à l'ugc à montigny le bretonneux
la rencontre de daniel chanteur raté et
endettée et de stéphane vendeur
d'électroménager plutôt doué au jeu
télévisé
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas si vous en avez conscience mais
vous avez un énorme potentiel
s'est fait jour les conventions se
laisserait